or a pico rush-hour in Mexico City for
residents here it's simply part of the
daily grind there are some 8 million
vehicles on the city's roads they
release
tons of dust particles into the air that
in turn creates smog
sit there the city doesn't just feel
dirty you can see it too sometimes you
look out and say oh it's a cloudy day
but then you realize no it's actually
smaller doesn't that mean that soon
respiratory illnesses are really common
it just shows that the air here isn't
especially good older vehicles
especially buses and trucks are the main
source of Mexico City's air pollution
they caused by far the most damage to
the environment the government wants to
take as many as possible off the roads
this is one way drivers who have their
old vehicle scrapped are eligible for
government subsidies an incentive to
switch to more environmentally-friendly
models Germany's International
Development Agency the GI Z as advising
city employees on how to run the program
some four hundred thousand trucks have
already been destroyed
McKenzie does Porsche what it for every
truck that's destroyed as part of the
scrappage scheme there is a reduction of
20 tons of greenhouse gas emissions per
year that leads to a significant
improvement in Mexico's air quality
quality to Mexico by even better than
trading in your old vehicle is hopping
on a bike instead these eco pcs can be
written for a small fee but has it led
to better air quality Mexico City tests
air quality at 29 different locations
staff at the city's Environment Ministry
take measurements of a range of
pollutants including the probable
carcinogen cadmium employees calculate
average levels and publish their
findings online the measurements often
point to poor air quality we have to
consider it in historical context the
air used to be bad all the time Mexico
City was one of the dirtiest cities in
the world but the environmental policies
of the last 25 years have led to a
significant reduction in pollution the
good news is that this trend is set to
continue and that despite the fact that
the city is still growing but another
solution is taking root to biologists
harinam aureus works at Mexico's largest
public research university the UN a.m.
he's planted an 800 square meter garden
on the roof of a private school the
building is located right in the city
center rooftop gardens like these have
become increasingly popular in Mexico
City there's no space down below for
parks or Gardens like these Mexico City
is overpopulated and there's nowhere to
plant green areas like this but they're
just what the city needs because the
plants produce oxygen and capture
pollutants in summertime the layer of
vegetation helps cool the buildings down
and in winter they provide some
insulation
that less heating is required most of
the plants here are succulent meaning
they store moisture in their fleshy
leaves they can also survive for long
periods without water as a result the
garden requires very little maintenance
it's ideal for busy people who want to
relax not work outdoors the researcher
has set up a kind of laboratory on the
roof of the university with the help of
his students he wants to find out which
plants are best suited to the rooftop
project he's determined only to grow
native Mexican plants in his gardens but
that's a surprisingly ambitious task
la ciudad de mexico 80% of the plants in
Mexico City whether in public parks
gardens or homes are exotic meaning they
don't come from Mexico but we have such
a diversity of plant species here where
the fourth or fifth most species were
its country in the world but we don't
really make use of it with these Roof
Gardens we want to encourage people to
use the biodiversity and learn to value
it one of the biggest proponents of
rooftop gardens is Environment Minister
Tanja Malaga SIA she's turned the
project into a political issue
she says the gardens promote well-being
as well as reducing smog the official
meant the entry same and many people
find it hard to get to a part to relax
during the week the roof terraces at
workplaces in the city centre give
people just that a moment of calm in
natural surroundings I think that cambio
este momento it helps relieve stress and
makes people feel good the government
has financed almost 22,000 square meters
of rooftop gardens they're located on
top of public buildings including
schools and hospitals
the gardens are not just attracting
human visitors either birds and insects
are benefiting as well this rooftops
ecosystem now boasts more than 90
different species and that number is set
to grow
you